president biden says he won't apologize
for saying russia's president cannot
remain in power he said yesterday it's
an opinion not a policy goal the
statement mr biden ad-libbed during a
visit to poland on saturday caused a
diplomatic uproar wijajang has more on
the president's response i'm not walking
anything back president biden stood by
his controversial comment about vladimir
putin for god's sake this man cannot
remain power
insisting the words were personal i was
expressing the moral outrage that i feel
and i make no apologies for it and not a
shift in u.s policy toward a russian
regime change nobody believes we're
going to take down i was going to talk
about taking down putin
nobody believes that the president was
asked if he was confident putin himself
saw it that way i don't care what he
thinks look here's the he's going to do
what he's going to do putin's top
spokesman called mr biden's comment
alarming and said only the russian
people will decide who is in power this
is completely
unacceptable
it's not for the united states president
to to decide who is going to be and who
is who is the president of the russian
federation he also issued a warning to
nato we do afraid of nato's getting
closer to our borders with its military
infrastructure please take care of that
don't push us into the corner
president biden dismissed criticism that
his remarks further provoked putin and
that they weakened nato's alliance in
fact the pentagon just announced that
the u.s has sent six navy fighter
aircrafts to germany called growlers
they will not be used over ukraine but
instead you beef up nato's defense the
equipment can be used to confuse enemy
radar in the sky
tony
a lot of military gear heading that
direction luigi thank you very much